the way American media covers attacks in
Paris of Brussels is often different
from how it covers similar attacks in
places like Beirut or Ankara landmarks
the world over lit for France this
neighborhood is a stronghold of
Hezbollah the Lebanese militia fighting
alongside Bashar al-assad's regime in
Syria so it makes you think this bias is
unfair and it's getting old but why does
it happen so disaster in England will
likely get more coverage than a similar
disaster in Indonesia
unfortunately there's also the
expectation that there will be an attack
in Syria or Pakistan or Lebanon or Kenya
a France and Belgium that's new and
seems a little close to home and yes in
addition to whatever cultural bias may
be at play there's also the issue of
limited resources and newsrooms as well
as the growing pressures of a 24-hour
news cycle that relies on clicks shares
and likes
not to mention anything that seems
repetitive can also start to get old for
audiences but not all newsrooms operate
this way and the thing is because the
media is in the business of information
what's put out and how it's put out
affects how people react and it also has
an effect on how audiences ultimately
empathize with cities and with victims
for instance whenever a Shia a
neighborhood in Beirut is bombed it's
referred to as a Hezbollah stronghold
despite it being a civilian area it
almost seems like a justification
whereas we'd never refer to Brussels as
a NATO stronghold because that would
take the focus off the people who were
senselessly killed so it's not just
about the frequency of violence or the
lack thereof or its novelty but also
about how people are more prone to
empathize with victims they can see
themselves in it's that empathy that
then becomes a call for prayers a tinted
profile picture or even support for
barring certain people from entering the
country
so our view of what happens abroad can
even affect our decisions back home